à l'entrée de ce boisé dans les cantons
de l'est
un producteur clandestins de cannabis
discute à l'écart avec des associés
c'est à l'intérieur de sa cache
artisanale super qu'ils nous rencontrent
depuis 15 ans celui qui veut se faire
appeler stéphane prétend verser des
redevances à des agriculteurs pour
exploiter leurs terres à chaque été
chaque récolte lui remplit les poches
1 il ya les bretons par un vent un bon
rythme des fois même plus y en a qui
m'ont dit ok c'est l'argent à saviola
dice a means pas médecin je veux ou la
ligne j'ai pas de sujet au ce gpo dessus
je peux je pars violente et personne ne
pourra voir argent à la gelée pour vol
et non plus une fois le cannabis
légalisé il baissera ses prix pour
concurrencer ceux de l'état déjà partout
au pays
la valeur sur le marché noir a déjà
commencé à diminuer en 2013 le grimp se
vendait en moyenne 9 dollars 40 au
canada en 2017
le même g était évaluée à 7 dollars 43
une baisse de 30% en moins de cinq ans
les revendeurs sont prêts pour la guerre
des prix ça ne va pas s'arrêter lorsque
l'état deviendra un compétiteur direct
affirme cet autre revendeur en
montérégie
[Musique]
ici au centre ville de montréal
les revendeurs de rue près de la place
émilie-gamelin mais surtout sur un taux
de thc nettement plus élevé que celui
qui revendra l'état défendue par
dominique 6010 porte le site hotels com
- de caracas avec ses petits bras
c'est comme si un roman que mélanie qui
fit de prostitution et revente ne croit
pas que ses revenus soient menacés par
la baisse de la valeur du cannabis ne le
portent supérieur mais d autres produits
sont plus payés avant je comprends que
ça une jackie chan découvrant leur job
au sommet de la pyramide des revendeurs
au canada contre le crime organisé
asiatique spécialisée dans l'exportation
illégales aux états unis un marché
clandestin évalué à 1 milliard 200
millions $ depuis deux décennies les
différentes cellules
la mafia asiatique ont pris le monopole
des cultures intérieure au canada le
nombre de cerfs clandestine s'est
rapidement multipliées au début je
recommençais à vancouver ça s'est
déplacée vers l'ontario et après son but
montréal grâce à des techniques de
culture intérieure avancé chacune de ces
serres peut produire un rythme effréné
de 8 récolte annuellement
en comparaison une culture extérieure le
rapporte qu'une récolte par été l'alibi
6 sur le territoire québécois
ça varie entre 800 à 10 700 $ la livre
selon la la qualité de cannabis une fois
transporté aux états unis la même libre
de cannabis des vendus pour environ 2500
$ us le cannabis vendu et livré
illégalement sur internet a de fortes
chances d'avoir poussé dans l'une des
serres clandestine de la mafia asiatique
[Musique]